these institutions have been so
compromised for so long
uh you've probably never seen an adult
sometimes i think elon looks like an
adult
i know that he has a wild lifestyle but
i also
see him looking like an adult what does
an adult look like exactly oh you know
somebody who
weighs things speaks carefully thinks
about the future beyond their own life's
lifespan somebody was a pretty good idea
of how to get things done isn't wildly
caught up in
punitive actions is more focused on
breaking new ground
than playing rent seeking games i mean i
really had a positive i was so
completely jazzed when elon musk ended
up as the world's richest person
he's like well that's interesting back
to work
it's just like that's that's what it is
that's what that's what a grown-up would
do
and it just made you know weirdly i said
something about isn't it amazing that
the world's
richest person knows what a lagrangian
is he made a terrible
lagrange joke about potentials but
yeah i mean i do think that ultimately
elon may be one of the closest things we
have to an adult and i can tell you that
the internet hyenas will immediately
descend as to what a fraudster he is for
pumping his stock price
talking his book and all this stuff shut
up
you